I used to share a lot about my toxic family dynamics on this app,
and I kind of stopped sharing
because somebody gave me really good advice.
Another creator that I admire
told me that you should always share from a place of,
like, a scar,
not an open wound, because especially with the internet,
people can be nasty. People can tell you all sorts of things.
After a while,
hundreds of comments that are negative will get to anybody.
And when you're having conflicting feelings about how you were raised
or your childhood or your family,
you know, a lot of those are not just black and white, right?
There's a lot of nuance there.
There's a lot of guilt and, like,
confusion.
And it was just not a healthy thing for me to continue sharing.
Since that point in time, a lot has happened in my family,
which is not my business to share.
But something that just happened in my life with my mother
was a positive step that I wanted to share with y'all
because I never thought this would happen.
I told my parents. Excuse me.
I told my mom about the book
Adult Children of Emotionally Immature Parents.
It's a book that's helped me a ton,
and I've talked about it on here at length,
and she's gonna read it because she never went through the process
that me and my sisters are going through now.
And in some ways, it's too late.
It's Too late to repair or, um,
change the relationships and the dynamics within our family.
But it's not too late for her to start healing.
And I just thought that was really surprising.
And as the parentified daughter,
very proud of her. As the hurt child, though,
I'm holding my breath.